the push to web api
let's have a look at the push web api
you will need to be logged in with your
aging face account which you can do by
executing this first cell or by typing
aging face minus cli login in a terminal
just enter your username and password
then click login
this will store an authentication token
in the cache of the machine you're using
now let's launch a fine tuning of a bird
model
on the glue collar data set
we won't go over the fine tuning code
because you can find it in any
transformers tutorial or by looking at
the videos linked below
what interests us here is how we can
leverage the model hub during training
this is done with the push to help equal
true argument passed in your training
arguments
this will automatically upload your
model to the app each time it is saved
so every epoch in our case
this allows you to resume training from
a different machine if the current one
gets interrupted
the model will be updated in your
namespace with the name of the output
directory you picked by default
you can choose another name by passing
it to the upmodel id argument
you can also push inside an organization
you are a member of by passing a full
repository name with the name of the
organization slash the model id you want
to pick
with that done we can just launch
training and wait a little bit
i'll cut the waiting time from the video
note that the model is pushed
asynchronously
meaning that the training continues
while your model is uploaded to the hub
when your first commit is finished you
can go inspect your model on the hub by
looking inside your namespace
and you will find it at the very top
you can even start playing with its
inference widget while it's continuing
the training
the collide dataset tasks the model with
determining if the sentence is
grammatically correct or not so we pick
an example of incorrect sentence to test
it
note that it will take a bit of time to
load your model inside the inference
apipe the first time you try to use it
we'll cut that time from the video
there is something wrong with the labels
but we'll fix it later in this video
once your training is finished
you should do one last push with the
trainer that pushed to a method
this is for two reasons
first this will make sure you're
uploading the final version of your
model if you didn't already for instance
if you used the save every n-step
strategy instead of every ebook
second this will draft a model card that
will be the landing page of your model
repo
once the commit is done let's go back on
our model page and refresh
we can see the draft of the model card
which includes information on which
pre-trained model we fine-tuned
the final evaluation lesson metric
the training hyper parameter used
the intermediate training results
and the framework versions we used so
that other people can easily reproduce
our results
on top of all that information the
trainer also included some metadata that
is interpreted by the urging face
website in the model card
you get the value of the matrix reported
in a nice widget as well as a link to a
leaderboard with paper with code
the tensorboard runs have also been
pushed to this repo and we can look at
them directly from the model hub by
clicking on the training metrics submenu
if you are not using the trainer api to
function your model you can use the push
tool method on the model and tokenizer
directly we'll use this to fix our
labels in the inference widget
the inference widget was using default
names for labels because we did not
indicate the correspondence between
integers and label names we can fix this
in the configuration by setting the
label to id and ad to label fields to
the proper values then pushing the modal
config to the hub
once this is done we can check on the
website and the modal is now showing the
proper label
now that the model is on the hub we can
use it from anywhere as we would any
other transformer model with the from
pre-trained method or with the pipeline
function
we just have to use the identifier from
the hub and we can see that the model
configuration and weights as well as the
tokenizer files are automatically
downloaded
try the push to web api on your next
training to easily share your model with
the rest of the world